[Music]
every year around Christmas the United
States Navy Band performs a holiday
concert in our nation's capital the band
is a large group of highly trained and
highly talented servicemen and women
Paula Reid spent the morning with them
at the Navy Yard in Washington before
their winter show Paulette they sound
amazing as they do every year amazing
and I wasn't sure what to expect because
we attended their first rehearsal before
the holiday show I was blown away it's
not the barrage you'd expect to hear
coming from a military installation
but these aren't your typical sailors
and this is not your typical band there
are some of the finest musicians that
you're going to hear in the country and
they're serving their country with their
talent
the Navy band has been around informally
almost as long as the Navy serving
through song at presidential
inaugurations funerals and other
government functions
[Music]
captain Ken Collins is the band's
commander his standards are
military-grade reflected in what you
hear and see on stage what's it like to
watch various generations of musicians
come through the badge and grow that
must be very rewarding the most
rewarding thing for me honestly is
getting the opportunity to work with
these outstanding individuals and watch
them all serve and succeed and grow
[Music]
musician first class Chelsea Vander pol
is one of those faces I was living in LA
doing that daily grind of the singer
life and at one point was working at a
pirate-themed dinner adventure and
started to realize I wanted to be part
of something maybe a little bigger than
myself tell me there's easier ways to
join a band boot camp I was really
terrified to go to boot camps I also
trained a lot and was really ready once
I found out I was a singer it was just
every single day there was a slew of
random people from other buildings that
were like sing us a song two decades ago
senior chief musician Michael blinky
nearly began a career as an attorney
[Music]
I think some of my early musical
training was singing in the car and then
when I got older I was finding myself
singing Prince and Michael Jackson songs
and realizing that everybody can't do
that and so I the more I did it the more
people wanted me to do it more and uh
and so singing fall said it was just
been something that I've been I get to
do in my my job when I walked into
rehearsal today I noticed people of all
ages men women people of all races
there's such a great camaraderie in this
group well music is a universal language
and it connects us all this is the
reason why we're here and it's the tool
that we use to connect the Navy to the
people
musician first class David Smith plays
trumpet in the band's brass section the
band's 170 members and it's 11 ensembles
perform more than 1300 shows per year
all around the globe
[Music]
it was my first year we learned a
japanese piece we had selected a song
that was written in honor of those that
they lost in the giant tsunami in 2011
that you happenes people there they
started weeping and they came up to us
and they shake our hands afterwards
through broken English they're they're
thanking us for honoring them honoring
their people honoring their country we
shared an experience established good
faith and we just we created a
relationship and it was like I can't
imagine anything more impactful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and these servicemen are not typically
subject to combat deployment the way
other sailors in the Navy are and it's
so interesting because first they
audition for the band and then if they
make it they join the Navy because I was
wondering about what happens if you
don't make it I joke with Chelsea there
are clothes your way but as you've just
heard you can understand why someone
would want this opportunity and also why
thousands of tickets to their Sunday
show sold out in about seven minutes Wow
great piece
we don't just cover the White House
thank you
you